دكتور محمود الافندي واستاذ في الاكاديميه
الروسيه اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور بدايه يعني
الكريم ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه بلا تعليق
منهما حتى الان على الحادث الى اي مدى يعد
التخلص من بريكوجين مكسبا لموسكو خاصه انه
ربما من اكثر المقربين لبوتينو عليه وربما
هو على درايه
بالعديد من الملفات الشائكه بالنسبه
لموسكو يعني هل التخلص منه هو في مصلحه
بوتين ام يتعارض مع مصالحه
المشاهدين طبعا لا تعليق من كل الجهات
الرسميه الروسيه الى انت عندما انتهاء
التحقيق بحطام بعد انتشار حطام الطائره
ودراسه الصندوق الاسود وعلى اساسها يمكن
ان يكون هناك تعليق اما بالنسبه
للشعب الروسي والحكومه الروسيه هي عداله
هي نوع من نوعين اما عداله السماء او
عادات الارض لانه بالنسبه لروسيا والحكومه
الروسيه والشعب الروسي بالجوجن وضع روسيا
على حافه الحرب الاهليه في تمرده العسكري
ولا ننسى ان في طريقه الى موسكو انزل خمس
طائرات هليكوبتر وطائرات انزال عسكريه
كانت فقط تعترضه لتوقفه فقط لذلك هناك 66
قتيل روسي كان موجود لذلك هو لديه اعداء
كثيره داخل روسيا وظن النخب الروسيه التي
لديها مصادر القوه واتكلم عن وزاره الدفاع
عن الاركان على وزاره الداخليه على
المخابرات العسكريه كل هدول اصبحوا اعداء
لذلك
يمكن ان نقول هناك احتمالين اما احتمال
عطل فني هاي عداله السماء او هناك استهداف
كان من عمليه انتقاميه ولكن ضمن ما يسمى
السيستم او النظام المخابرات بالانتقام من
شخصيه بريجوجل
وتدعيات هذا الحادث على العلاقه بين فاجنر
والنظام الروسي
الاول الشيء هو ليس نظام الروسي ولكن
الحكم الروسيه تحديدا
لا ابدا يعني هو ليس هناك يعني
شهرين الماضيه
الى القياده الروسيه وغيرتيه كل قياديين
يعني الان اصبح القيادين بقدر الذي قتلوا
البارحه او توفى بارحا نتيجه يعني حتى
الان
علاقه لهم الان مع فان تقريبا
استلم اندريه وهو الرمادي كل لم يبقى تحت
سيطره الرمادي ذهبوا الى بيلاروسيا الان
في بيلاروسيا اعتقد ان الرئيس لوكاشنكا
سيحل الامر عن طريق ابن قيادي جدد في ذلك
لذلك تتاثر اي شيء
ان يلقى ما يسمى مصيره فهنا الامر مهم جدا
يعني ان هناك ليس هناك ما يقول هناك نظام
داخلي لوسي عرف عسكري لوسي معروف عليه من
ايام الامبراطوريه الروسيه الاتحاد
السوفيتي الاتحاديه الخائن يجب ان ينتهي
هذا الاصوات تعال في الفتره الاخيره
يخص بالفعل له تاثير على فئه معينه
لا ابدا هو هو شخص ليس سياسي هو ابدا هو
شخص حتى ليس عسكري هو نوع من انواع رجل
اعمال واشتهر بس في فقط العمليات العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا يعني اشتهر بمعركه
ضخمه بالفعل معركه كانت بطوله لا يعني لا
احد لا احد يقول لا لهذه العمليه كانت
وقال الرئيس انه ابطال في هذه المعركه
ولكن المشكله توجيه السلاح يخسر كثير من
الشعبيته خسر كثير من الشعب عن طريق
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه لبعض الانتقاد ما
يسمى
الانتقاد القياده الروسيه او وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه الروسي بدون ضربه حديديه على
اوكرانيا ولا يدور عمليه عسكريه خاصه
شامله هذا كان الشعارات بالجوجل في الفتره
الاخيره لذلك انا في رايي الشخصيه اصبحت
اشكاليه داخل الروسي فيمكن ان نقول ان ان
بشكل اشكال وجوده اصبح غير يعني غير من
داخل روسيا ولا خارج روسيا هذا امر مهم
جدا اصبح شخصيه اشكاليه هون نقول ان هناك
يعني كما يقول التعددت الاسباب والموت
واحد يعني انتهى الشخص يعني فينا نقول
التحقيقات ستقول ولكن التحقيقات لن تؤدي
الى شيء حتى لو بعد شخصيات روسيه من نخبه
يعني حاول حاول اغتيال اوزان الطائره
اعتقد ان التحقيقات لن تؤدي الى شيء لانه
نعلم جيدا النظامات السريه تستطيع ان تزيل
كل الادله يعني انا برايي حتى لن تحصل على
يد في مقتل فكل الامور كل الامور
هذا هذا الذي حصل شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
محمود الافندي استاذ في الاكاديميه
الروسيه كنت معنا من موسكو